[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to dirty RT this is episode
two or chapter two my name is Rob this
is Jake we are trying to make Arthur
Morgan in this game the dirtiest
smelliest biggest lowlife piece of butt
as well as making him fat and making his
beard grow we're trying to make a piece
of [ __ ] character pretty much and we're
well on our way we went ahead or you did
at least and there was a glitch of
there's a glitch where you can basically
like pick up infinite amounts of gold
bars you know we got 30 so we're gonna
have a lot of money and that's good
because we Jake and I were talking we
kind of realized that we wanted to
expedite all this opposed to like
spending eight episodes to get a full
beard and to be fair if Arthur Morgan or
if dirty Artie had the option to do this
I'm sure he a hundred percent would see
like we could sell 15 grand we're good
we're gonna go back to Valentine and tie
up some loose ends and get a raccoon hat
why don't we stop at the general store
here quickly and just get a grub of food
totally and get some more hair tonic so
about here there are ten stages to the
length of your hair apparently if you
drink three hair tonics it's eight times
the growth or hair growth so we're gonna
try to drink three or buy as many as we
can and then go to sleep and then that
should be the quickest way to get our
hair long and we just basically rinse
and repeat that no rinsing though just
repeating the other thing about getting
fat there are I didn't know this there
are calories associated with things you
can eat so the highest calorie intake or
item that has the highest calorie is
big-game so at some point maybe this
episode we're gonna go get we're gonna
go hunt big game and those are
alligators bears wolves or Cougars now
I'm sure you can agree to this is that
if I'm thinking about like density of
said animal alligators are everywhere in
the swamp so I say we go and just kill
alligators and eat their meat for days
at some point all right but that's down
the road we're gonna we're gonna do a
bit by bit here so leave in like a POS
already down and so we're going to
Valentine all right yeah score Valentine
I ride there should we take the train
again
never take the train just to speed
things up all right I'm gonna bay a
little bit finally we had some horse poo
you could do that oh yeah that's hot
horse poo I'm gonna do like a little
backwards there we go cool cool cool
I think we're good I think we're good
too okay so after we get our hat let's
let's try to do some hair hair growing
all right like we'll just get out more
hair tonic I've already downed a couple
of them
yeah let's at least get like no let's do
a couple days so the way the best way to
do that apparently is you know you go to
like a hotel I think is probably the
best well drink three go to sleep wake
up go to the store buy three drink them
go to bed and we'll speed it up dirty
already hibernating yeah you are you are
real gross right now I'll slow down on
the beans a little bit we got to save
some in between uh long stretches of
sleep not check you in this is probably
the muddiest town in all of Mount
Montana
maybe strawberries pretty money too
what maybe because I just had that bar
fight maybe I need to sleep more
you'll ugly bastard huh oh that's
definitely longer what your beard oh
yeah yeah that's kinda we're getting
there we're getting there what my guy
talk [ __ ] alright hopefully the bar is
up and running again yeah are you God
being a fight with him now worst hotel
guests ever oh this is so dumb okay
sleep again don't like add it's finicky
Oh cuz I've been sleeping too much
lately [ __ ] well I have I have the room
this might kill you hey you need me to
shut you up
what about room you're like so that
guest that creepy-ass guests like yeah
he just busts in the front door everyday
drinks
hair tonic and goes that's all he's been
doing for the last two weeks yeah we're
getting there we're getting there
I mean it's looking good is our morning
ritual now was it like this I kinda
wanna say it was for me too yeah I think
it's empty for a while while he cleans
up you want to do one more day okay
we'll do one more day I'll get some more
beard tonic oh and then yeah and then
let's do Gators that's funny is like
they're there this isn't that like
far-fetched for like a like for this to
be like a real person littering so
needless like there's no he's just
giving no sheets no just throwing this
anywhere oh it's getting long dude you
see his hairs like yeah his back yeah
yeah yeah for sure
all right well I say you buy three
tonics and then leave okay and we'll go
to the bayou
let's a love the idea of just dirty
Aarthi are already coming back to this
bar like five times that you guys open
yeah you guys open yeah big beans is
spilling out maybe she a man so excited
[Music]
oh whoa we need this body I say we kill
ya it's oh that's good mud yes alligator
meat far better animation problem okay
shot it I'm being shot at this is
getting a little messy dead alright
let's set up camp perfect beautiful it's
funnier that dirty arty of all people is
cooking meat and shoving in his bag for
later alright so here here's how I think
we should maybe end it is once you're
done with this eat maybe one more drink
your hair tonic go to sleep I say we we
kill a animal and skin it and try to
make it gross and then go to a bar and
throw it
throw it on like a table in the bar okay
we're getting bigger leaves rides by
superfast
didya honestly I've got to even look at
them so should I take the skinned corpse
yeah hundred percent it's gotta be gross
and I bet it rots easier - God give me
covered in blood - I think oh we can buy
a top hat - in the meantime I think
there's a top hat of son Danny we got
the money yeah yeah I mean you are in a
very fancy town you might as well
address book cleaner somehow oh shoot I
did the magical hat dang it I knew it
was gonna happen
Wow that horse uses head to knock it out
oh oh my god geez Jesus who is that dude
right there two left all right well
there's bar fight
there that's it all right well cool we
we did a lot we're definitely getting
there look at him he with that hat
especially makes him look fatter but he
is definitely getting there all right
cool
well that about does it I say next week
we'll still try to get that raccoon hat
I really wanna I really want to see it
on him oh you win this time coppers Oh
psych I think you shot your horse I say
we go maybe for a bear attack or
something like that maybe lasso a
handful of people and ride into town
with them that hat is wonderful all
right cool thanks Jake and thank you
guys for watching stay tuned next week
for another episode of dude yeah
you
[Music]